hello I'm gav I'm Dan we're The Slammer
guys this video is about blanks blanks
are used instead of real bullets when
you want to do things like movies or
military exercises you get the flash in
the bang yeah without the bullet
essentially everything except the bullet
that's right yeah so instead of a bullet
it's got like a crimped end and some
propellant in there but the propellant
still has to come out yeah and still
does damage still has to be compressed
by being in here so it has a bang rather
than just going I actually have never
used one you've never used one before I
was gonna say you've been blanked but
you've never used one okay well this is
a real sort of
nine mil ball round yes and here's our
unspent blank and this is our spent so
basically a set of a load of gunpowder
being behind the bullet there's there's
no bullet and then it just crimps the
end it's essentially the same except
without a projectile but it was still
deafen you it was still literally wound
you with the stuff that comes out yeah
absolutely 100 all right well let's put
that to the test okay today we're using
the Phantom TMX 7510 we'll start at 82
000 frames a second and the first Target
is an egg
wow
is
a lamo it does and have the like oomph
of a regular round it's just sort of
like a little pop but it smashed the egg
slimy yeah so it doesn't have any gas
pressure to force the slider back
because it needs to compress the gas
against the back of the bullet but
there's no bullet so it's just yeah it
basically yeah exactly
um so it can't cycle to the next round
unless you put what's called a BFA in
which is a blank firing attachment which
they use a lot of the time in films and
in the military the ones in the military
that I was using had like they're a big
yellow thing on the front yeah ready
oh
oh look at all the gump that comes out
of there
so I can't tell whether it's just the
air or whether it's the the fragments
that create the end well look you spark
you can see yeah there's like little
Sparks on the edge then busts it open
yeah look it's it's now just being blown
away look there's little bits of it
still going into the yolk and stuff you
wouldn't want to be that egg would you
there's loads of it you would not okay
let's do it again but I'll be at like 45
degree angle here we go
oh that seemed beefier somehow that was
really loud didn't it yeah
take note here of the fact that this
regular speed camera which is 50 frames
a second didn't see a single frame of
any muzzle flash
it was absolutely purple dashed it was
peppered that was a really like fiery
one there
that was crazy how much like Flames come
out and all the bits that was really
fiery look all the Sparks like each
piece each individual bit it cracks the
egg it's like it's like a mini shotgun
you see that yeah it's like Tiny Bird
shot yeah it's like ant shot ant shot
yeah and then it breaks the egg in like
a thousand different places and then all
the gas pressure just blows it away
there's not like High Velocity spatter
but it still wrecks the egg entirely oh
it annihilates it the bullet always went
in and ejected tiny little pieces of
shell with that one it's just like
taking a shotgun to it and then going
really hard
okay next Target slightly meatier meat
wasn't just a bit of hair it's a little
bit of a ham yeah that is a weird sight
I'll be honest in the middle of a quarry
it's pretty windy the Ham's flapping
around well the ham knows what's coming
for it
made ready
you ready ready
oh my God that just went I was expecting
a few holes in the hand yeah same
I'm almost as blown away as that ham was
flip oh here's a bit look
oh God
okay that is serious that's really far
it's really far
oh God
whoa it just rips it apart in the center
there you can see absolutely just murks
the middle of that house it's the whole
of it oh that is gruesome that is I
don't can we show this I don't know but
it might be like your uvula or get
demonetized oh yeah because there's no
projectile it just it like made the ham
the projectile that's unreal it just
tore it a new one
I literally did let's get that from the
other side okay
the harm was flapping around
but yeah oh do you see what I had to do
there I had to like Wrangle the house
[Laughter]
that was a mid-shot ham wrangle
that honestly there's tiny little flecks
of ham everywhere it definitely needs a
ambulance
this video I can already tell this video
is going to be crap
oh my God
oh that is nasty you like crazy Ripple
as well
each tiny little Fleck of powder I guess
has enough Force to just go straight
through the ham like it weighs something
it doesn't weigh anything it just
disintegrates it it just Mists the ham
it's not gruesome footage but it just
makes you imagine
like what what could happen
yeah
uh should we try a water balloon
what's that about three feet away yeah
let's see if we lose the balloon from
this distance I have a feeling we will
okay
make him ready
are you ready ready
oh
yeah we did wow I'm I'm pretty surprised
by the range I wonder if we'll see less
of the like pushing Air Force on it
oh you can see the Blurred
bit and see the shot yeah so it seems
like a lot of it actually wasn't
powerful enough to go through you can
see it just bouncing off yeah but there
was one bit up here that was
I guess slightly bigger or going faster
that went through the balloon caused the
rip interest so I'd say that's at the
very edge of the oh look you can see the
splash marks where the other bits hit
yeah yeah this is definitely the edge
like you say the sort of effective range
of a blank round I would I certainly
wouldn't want to stand in front three
feet away from it
absolutely not yeah it's a beauty mate
oh oh
that just come back at you somehow yeah
that one was more of a uh I feel like
that one was more of a beefy round like
it was did you hear it it was like a
real yeah that was a that was a
heftensite maybe these aren't the most
consistent
yeah that was an OP one look at the heat
wave wow oh my God that was a serious
one that was I have not exposed but this
brightness that's a cool moment though
almost getting like a schlier in effect
with the Sun
pointing out that the shock wave as well
as the expanding gas about a hundred
different scars on the balloon and then
it's just blown out from the fireball
hits as well
I think we've proven the point I think
it's got some quite nice slash gory
looking footage well that was Carnage
and I was expecting Carnage about this
much yeah this is the Carnage we filmed
gruesome are you specifically referring
to the ham because I'm thinking of the
ham I haven't stopped thinking about the
ham until I saved it I think I'll eat
some now it just does go to show how
dangerous these can be and they're not
to be taken lightly you know yeah don't
um don't fool around with a blank but
also not with a bullet either so I think
everyone knew that already
it's not it's not a PSA we had to see
your information
I've learned a lot I just think it was
nice to visualize it I've uh I've never
seen one up close or in slow-mo no I
didn't really for the longest time years
ago know what a blank really was yeah me
either yeah well hopefully you enjoyed
that video make sure you subscribe if
you're into slow-mo it's a nice other
video for you to watch we'll see you
next time bye
so
he's blanked me
foreign
[Laughter]